good morning everyone and welcome to
this meeting of mids District Council
cabinet I'm councelor Andy melon leader
of MSU District Council and I'll be
chairing this meeting uh just to remind
you of some domestic arrangements please
ensure your microphones are turned off
when not in use please do not interrupt
other speakers or hold separate
conversations While others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave uh
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off and finally we
will be using EV voting for this meeting
on the modern. goov app so please could
cabinet members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the
app um I'd like to remind everyone
present this meeting is being broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except whether
are confidential or EX exemp
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you also consenting to being
recorded by the council and the possible
use of those images and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training
purposes the council members of the
public and the Press May record film or
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully
excluded um I just want to say welcome
to the officers who've uh turned up
today to um to present and and be part
of the discussions you're a long way
away I do need some binoculars I think
from this end to sort of see everyone
but U nice to see you here can I move to
the agenda please uh item one is
apologies for
absence n receed chair item two to re
receive Declarations of pecuniary other
registerable or non-reg able interests
by members are there any to
declare none thank you item three MCA
Stoke 23 Stoke 16 to confirm the minutes
of the meeting which was held on the 5th
of September
2023 uh are there any points regarding
the accuracy of the minutes I've already
got a couple of minor amendments which
have been flagged up uh paragraph
26.5
uh the response would be should is been
changed to the response will be just a
correction of grammar there and
paragraph
26.7 um capital capital expenditure
would be carried over from the previous
year um so just two minor Corrections
are there any
others could I have a proposal please
councelor eburn and a seconder councelor
winch the governance officer will now
conduct the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress uh that's six votes for that's
unanimous
chair thank you very much I'll sign
those minutes at the end of the meeting
me uh item four to receive notification
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petition
scheme none received item five questions
by counselors none received item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees there are no matters referred
chair uh thank
you item 7even is the forthcoming
decisions list uh which I'm sure we've
had a look at um there's several
decisions listed there that we're making
today and then we have several for the
uh full Council on the 26th of October
and then the next round are the um
decisions in the cabinet meeting on the
7th of
November
um I did notice there's nothing in there
on the jlp I think we are expecting that
to come to council
in
November
okay cancel Ean and chair I wondered
about the
housing account the 30-year business
plan for housing whether that was going
to be coming at some point or whether
that was part of the budget as it
were anyone got an answer on that so it
would be a separate item but uh yes it
hasn't been confir the timing
yeah just because people would like to
see that as soon as possible so um that
can be on the list as soon as
thanks any further comments or questions
on the um forthcoming decisions
list if not we'll move on to item eight
uh this is paper MCA stroke 23 stroke 17
the variation of agreement of the shared
Revenue partnership um I understand that
M list is not well to so we've got Bob
Palmer here um representing and Shirley
jarlet from um ipge B Council welcome um
but I'm going to ask the cabinet member
for finance and resources uh councelor
eburn to introduce the
report thank you very much chair so this
is the U variation of the agreement for
the shared Revenue partnership um and
I'm very pleased to welcome today as the
chair said um shley jlot who's the
assistant director at iwit B Council and
and um she takes the role of head of
service for the shared Revenue
partnership and for those of you who
aren't aren't so much aware as it does
say in the paper the shared revenues
partnership was set up in in 2011 and
became operational in April 2011 and is
a partnership between mids babber and
mids suffk um originally set out to make
cost savings by sharing all
Administration relating to revenues and
benefits so that includes council tax
business rates um Universal Credit and
so on
and it is hosted at iish Bar Council and
because of the arrangement between the
three authorities there needs to be
obviously an legal agreement to set that
up and to have that and it hasn't been
that hasn't been reviewed since 2015 so
it was felt opportune to actually review
the um that agreement and um make any
changes necessary and the paper before
you includes those changes that need to
be made the majority of these um again
as the paper says are housekeeping type
um changes in terms of things that have
come into place so new new policies and
rules changes of titles changes the ways
of of doing things and so on so it has
just been kind of um fully updated as it
were if
um it's quite technical some of the
issues there so if anyone does have any
questions I will probably um direct them
towards um shley jarlet um but unless um
officers um have anything further to add
um particularly shley if you got
anything further to add to that um
otherwise I would propose the
recommendation no I have nothing further
to add thank you thank you shelle so I'd
be happy to propose a recommendation at
3.1 chair and I would look for a
seconder thank
you do we have a second councelor
winch thank you very much um any
questions from cabinet members on this
uh on this paper
uh there's no other members here to ask
questions so I think we can open the
item Up For Debate does anyone want to
debate this item councilor winch yeah I
I don't think there should be
controversial because it doesn't
anticipate any significant changes in
the role of the shared Revenue
partnership there's a couple of things
to mention in the document there's the
ability to call in which I think is a
good a good idea because it it's
important that every area the council
subject to scrutiny and the other
element that's changed is a separate
section that clarifies the delegation
responsibilities and I think it makes it
a bit easier to understand what's
actually going on so I'd like to give my
support for these
changes thank you anyone else want to
make any
comments counc Eber thank you chair just
before we go to the to the vote um just
to make the point that the shared
revenues partnership is a very good
partnership working cross Ross the three
councils and very very efficient um in
what it does but in addition to the um
the the sort of day-to-day work it does
also um
provide a Administration for help for
vulnerable households um such as
um dis U discretionary housing payments
and the recent energy Fuel and fuel kind
of rebates that um many members of the
public were eligible for so it does have
an extremely important function so I'm
very pleased to um support um this and
ensure that the partnership continues um
in a well-run fashion thank you
chair thank you very much uh I think
that summarizes the situation very well
we're very happy with the shares
revenues partnership it works well for
us and um so we can move to uh the the
vote on the recommendation 3.1 that
cabinet authorizes the director of
corporate resources in consultation with
the cabinet member for finance to enter
into the deed of variation at appendix a
to the report and I will now ask the
governance officer to conduct the
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
that's six whats for chair that's
unanimous thank you very much uh thanks
to the officers for attending I'm sure
you've got other things you you could be
doing so thank you for
coming so we'll move on to item nine uh
this is paper
MCA stroke 23 stroke 18 uh the cost of
living review of the sixth month plan
and
Beyond and um I will now introduce this
report as Cabinet member for performance
and resilience and we have um Samantha
Lake uh corporate manager for customer
operations we have Eliza Dale cost of
living
coordinator um and Sarah Wilcock here as
well so um I will do my introduction and
then um if there's any questions that I
can't answer I'm sure those officers
will be pleas to
help so the mids suffer cost of living
review the reports provide a summary of
the work undertaken in the last six
months and also the latest draft sixth
month action plan which is the third
action plan the councils have developed
in response to the cost of living crisis
um the work on this is uh has been a
coordinated effort across many Services
of the council and also including key St
stakeholders such as the citizens advice
Bureau to to support residents in
several key areas uh maximizing their
income
accessing access accessing advice if I
can say it food
insecurity fuel poverty and then health
and
well-being and we all aware that the
cost of living is a an everchanging
landscape um inflation has fallen back
from its peak and in fact it's reported
today that food prices have actually
gone down but there are still ongoing
concerns regarding regarding uh the cost
to households uh the cost of energy as
we head into the colder months and of
course our citizens advised partners are
reporting increased levels of debt and
negative
budgets so the cost of living continues
to be a key priority for us and we're
proposing alongside the latest six-month
plan to develop a longer term approach
focusing on prevention and building on
our partnership
working so just to um highlight a few
things our cost of living group of
officers have continued to work with
participation from the shared revenues
Partnerships we were just talking about
communities housing uh the customer
facing offices and economic
development um we've developed resources
for staff including a fuel poverty
toolkit um a frequently asked questions
fact sheet for Frontline workers and
then clearly our Communications uh
department has been involved in targeted
Communications to raise awareness of
support uh for the various schemes and
then we had broader campaigns across
digital and print media which have
actually um achieved over a million
opportunities for people to to see them
between uh January and June this year
which I think is quite
incredible just to look ahead and the
refreshed action
plan contains um various areas including
continuation of Grants to support
households we're piloting a referral
system with angli and water for those
those on Lower incomes to be moved to a
social
tariff we can continue to use
Communications campaigns to raise
awareness of support available and to
reduce stigma and we want to develop a
deeper level of insight into our
customers particularly those who who get
into
areas um and we also want to um pilot
some initiatives which provide support
for young people to gain the kind of
skills uh and access opport opportuni
that will prevent from getting into
debt and later on we'll be hearing about
the implementation of an employer
supported volunteering scheme which will
also
help so as we look ahead we're keen to
consider how we can broaden our approach
to address the longer term drivers of
hardship and we need to have a
consistent commit commitment to reducing
poverty embedded right across the
council Services uh we're going to hear
later about the refresh of our corporate
plan uh and that will feed into this
work
to uh we want to make best use of our
links with town and Parish councils uh
to better understand things at a hyper
local level and to raise awareness of
support but that's just a brief overview
um and I'm happy to from the chair
propose that we
uh we agree this report and and the
action plan can I have a second there
please councel well thank you very
much any questions from members of the
cabinet
here canc
Ean um thank you chair I just with
regards to uh the um hyper localness of
it and the um liais on with um parish
and town councils and I was just going
to ask in terms of sort of the frequency
of that or how that was um um going to
be enabled perhaps that's a question for
an officer
chair yeah we do have our parish and
town liais on meetings which I think
sixth monthly if I'm correct but I
wonder if um Sam if you've got something
to add to
that thank you chair so we want to
actually ask the town and parishes um
for their for their views on this and
the best way to engage them um but we do
also want to um utilize those existing
town and Parish Leo on meetings so it'll
be a blended approach but we will be
looking to reach out to town and
parishes to um gain their views on how
they best like to be engaged as well
thank you good thank
you any other questions from cabinet
members if not we can open up this item
for debate does anyone want to uh make a
contribution councelor Stringer thank
you chair uh just wanted to sort of
highlight one area in the report uh that
starts at 4
4.12 um with the record of 73 home
homelessness applications uh you know
mostly 30% increase on last year uh and
the leading cause being people being
evicted as it were from private rented
accommodation uh that that just as a bit
of a statement really that that shows
that the work we do in terms of
providing housing is even more vital
than it ever was and us being able to
provide uh different tenures from the
market is is uh is incredibly vital uh
so just wanted to say uh you know this
is going to be a challenge for us I
think to to make sure that we carry on
that work and increase the depth and
breadth of what we're able to offer uh
not much of a question or a debating but
a bit of a statement but it just show
that that work certainly highlighted
there is incredibly
vital
ccor winch yeah i' just like to say what
an impressive set of activities have
gone on over the past year uh as
somebody relatively new to the details
of what a council does I wasn't aware of
a lot of the things that have been going
on and it's a very comprehensive plan
going forward there's one thing I noted
um in uh recommendation 5.5 about the
vulnerable customer policy which is
going to be scoped by the shares Revenue
partnership I wonder whether the V able
resident policy ought to be quite a core
element of this plan uh in that I think
we need to look at every touch point
that the council has with a vulnerable
resident and how we react in in that
circumstance and I think that should be
drawn now and giv a bit more
emphasis yeah thank you for that CC
e um thank you chair I just um I think
all of this work is really vital and I'm
really pleased to see the more um
emphasis on actually the real local
level because I think it's in local
communities that um PE people know their
own communities and I think to be able
to link that that in with this is be
really helpful for um particularly that
those who are in need um and just to
point on the um sort of inflation and
interest rates while they might be
coming down it doesn't necessarily mean
that that costs all coming down it said
you know food prices as the ch said fell
by but only by 0.1% but grocery
inflation is still 99.9% so um it it's
still you know a a really um hard
situation for those um who are who are
in need at the moment and so I think we
need to you know really continue with
all this work and I think it's really
vital and I we have also got our
um a a scheme coming forward soon on on
housing insallation which also could
could help on in this in this area of
work um but I do think it's it's really
important that we continue to address
this and both the you know the causes of
poverty mitigating it and particularly
supporting those in need so I will be
supporting this thank you
chair thank you very much any further
contributions to the
debate okay I I do agree with Council
winch that um residents need to access
our services in a number of different
ways uh you know however much we um work
on digital inclusion there will always
be those people who are not comfortable
accessing us uh
online um so we need to you know we need
to make sure that uh people can get
through on the phone that they can see
us face to face if they really need to
do that so I think you're absolutely
right we need to look at the um how
people access our services from the
Viewpoint of people who are vulnerable
I think agree with CCC eurn that housing
costs are going to be a real challenge
in the months ahead uh you know um we
don't know where interest rates are
going to go next but um housing costs
are very very high for a lot of families
and the situation with rental properties
is is is unclear but I'm very confident
in the work that our staff are doing
very grateful to the hard work Eliza and
Sam are doing and the rest of the
officers so um um keep up the good work
on this on this area which is really
important for
us um so we have the
recommendations in the report which I'll
just find the right
page recommendation 3.1 to note phase
three of the cost of living action plan
and endorse the commitment to develop
the longer term approach to preventing
poverty which seeks to understand the
underlying drivers of poverty across
both districts at a hyper local level
through continued work with internal and
external stakeholders and to include
wider engagement with town and Parish
councils and I'll now ask the governor's
vote officer to conduct the
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress on your
app
thank you there is six votes for that's
chair thank you very much so we just
need to take a short break while we sort
things out for the next item oh five
minutes
okay
okay I think we're ready to resume the
meeting now thank you
members uh we're going to move on to
item 10 uh paper MCA stroke 23 st9 the
corporate plan
refresh and um I will in uce a report as
leader of the council so you have to
listen to me again um but um we have
Shaheen Warren here welcome who's the
principal practice lead at new local who
are helping us with the engagement on
this um we would have had Joe Hobs here
um but she's not well and I believe
she's listening in uh Joe and Rob I hope
you soon feel
better um anyway I'll introduce a report
and then we will
um see the presentation so since the May
elections our new Administration has
been delivering an initial action plan
but we've also been working on a
long-term vision and our strategic
priorities to address the challenges we
face and make migu mids suffer District
even
better it will always be the council's
role to provide high quality services
but we are ambitious and want to see our
towns and communities really Thrive so
today we are setting our vision but our
message to the public is this is what we
are planning tell us what you
think we want people to tell us what
they think is important what we're plan
what we're plan to do that they are not
sure about what they think we've missed
and what matters most to their
community and we want to capture wide
ranging views from a diverse group of
people and we want everyone to help
shape the future of their own
communities now our vision covers issues
raising from the homes we live in to the
food that we produce and eat from our
local culture and Heritage to the skill
people need for the 21st
century at the heart of our plans is
sustainability doing even more to
address climate change building
resilience and preparing people for an
uncertain
future we need to increase the supply of
affordable homes fundamental to strong
communities and making these homes
whether they are already built or in the
planning process fit for the
future we want to enable a bright future
for our town centers ensuring they
become thriving places which connect
communities and bring people together
and we have to find solutions to poor
rural transport which can be so limiting
for people of all
ages now midu is rich in Heritage and
culture and we want to maximize the
Fantastic opportunities this offers
attracting visitors and providing great
experiences for
residents and also we want people to
lead healthier and more more active long
lives so why is it so important to get
all this right we need to put ourselves
in the shoes of today's children and
teenagers in another 20 or 30 years and
think about what Legacy we will have
left for them when they look back what
are they going to say we should have
done more of what are they going to be
angry with us
about serious long-term change takes
time discussion and thought it also
requires us to work with our
communities we want to lead the district
in a more sustainable Direction but we
also need to take people with us and so
first we need to
listen our draft corporate plan can be
found on pages 111 to 119 of the cabinet
papers this is far from a complete and
Polished document at this stage but it
does set out the broad scope of what the
administration wants to do with a long
list of potential projects and
approaches now today we are launching
lach ing the consultation with all
members with Council staff with
stakeholders and with residents we'll be
using a variety of tools and techniques
so that we hear from a wide range of
voices including those who are seldom
heard and we've commissioned new local
to help us with this process we want to
end up with a plan that everyone feels
they have some ownership and a stake in
even if they don't agree with everything
it should not be just the
administration's plan it should be the
councils now before I ask for a proposer
and seconda I'm going to ask for Shaheen
Warren from new local to give us a
presentation thank
you great thanks so much for their warm
introduction oh brilliant it's up there
um my name is Shaheen Warren I am the
principal practice lead from an
organization um called new local thank
you so much for having me today and for
um giving me a few moments to walk
through a present presentation that
really outlines our engagement plan um
as part of the overall corporate plan
refresh um I have a little bit of a
connection to this part of the world my
in-laws live in long mford they love it
here um so I am a little bit familiar
with the the various kind of regions and
districts um here um today I'm going to
walk you through the sort of Engagement
plan that supports the overall corporate
plan refresh talk to you a little bit
through the strategy that we've gone
through to kind of come up with the plan
and some of the kind of delivery
activities that we'll be taking on in
the coming weeks and then there'll be an
opportunity for any questions um that
you might
have is this going to
work we good brilliant um so just a
Whistle Stop tour around who new local
is and what we do um so we're an
independent not for-profit think tank um
and we offer a number of different kind
of service offerings um primarily we
maintain a sort of network of 70 plus
councils of which I believe babber midu
District Council is a member um and all
the councils are sort of united in this
commitment to drive Community power um
in the places that they live um meaning
that they have a belief that communities
have a vital voice in the process of um
being able to drive and Lead sustainable
community-led Public Services um we also
have a kind of small um uh But Mighty
research and policy team who work on the
ideas um that we face in our society
today so everything from kind of climate
change economic development Health
inequalities and really applying that
Community power lens to show that there
is a different way of doing things um
that enables us to achieve positive
outcomes for everyone um and then I sit
um in the practice team um and have been
working with the babber mids project
team here um to really transform those
ideas of Community power interaction so
we work shoulder-to-shoulder with local
authorities and councils all up and down
the country um to show them how to
collaborate with people communities um
and transform the way they work um and
just to give you a bit of a sense this
is a sort of um spread of the councils
who belong to our Network um there's a
kind of diverse range there and then
also we're supported by some corporate
Partners who are also invested in ideas
around Community power and want to
collaborate more across the public
sector and public services here in the
UK so as a brief introduction to who we
are and moving on to what our goals are
for the corporate plan refresh um and
how we see the engagement kind of
supporting that process um so um as
councelor already outlined um you're
embarking on a really ambitious plan um
to enrich in the sort of um lives and
communities that live um in mids suffk
and what we want to be able to do is to
connect directly with Community Voices
um to make sure that that that draft
action plan is really enriched by um
community and Resident voices but also
voices from um your partners um and
internal kind of Staff who'll be kind of
driving the initiatives that go along
with that um so we've gone through a
process for the last two months of
really understanding what the aims and
objectives of that engagement process
should look like what does it mean for
the different groups that we will be
engaging with and how do we really best
tailor our approach to meet people where
they're at um so broadly that folds up
into two different groups so we have our
internal stakeholders some of what we're
doing today presenting the plan to you
all and then working with um internal
teams to really understand the
implications of an engagement approach
for the corporate plan um and also build
consensus around driving more Community
engagement across the council um and
then secondly we're doing um a bunch of
Engagement with external stakeholders um
primarily with your communities and your
res residents um to help inform um those
emerging priorities um so we're working
you know kind of new local with the
project team and we've also brought in
some very specialist um Community
engagement um expertise into the team to
really drive the community engagement
activities that I'll walk you through in
a minute uh in terms of our timeline
like I said we've been in planning mode
so far we hope to be able to launch the
community engagement this week um and
that will run roughly until the 15th of
November um and then we will feed those
insights um back into um the corporate
plan development process um and
hopefully have something in Draft before
Christmas um so just a word on what
we're going out with so um the
priorities are really ambitious um we
really want to be able to represent them
in the best way to the diverse
communities that we're going out to and
so what you'll see here is um both a
kind of tailoring of the language um
around the priorities but really keeping
to the sort of um kind of course spirit
and essence of what you're trying to
deliver um and we do that for a couple
of reasons um one is to make sure that
the priorities um connect with the
communities that we're going out to that
they feel relevant in their everyday
lives and that communities are really
able to identify with them in a
meaningful way um another reason that we
do that is to make sure that we're able
to kind of touch on on on all the
diverse issues that are represented here
and really get important and meaningful
feedback that will inform the sort of
action plan moving into the
future how are we're going to do that um
so on the right hand side here what
you'll see is um an overview of the
content framework that we're going to
use so we've broken down um into four
key sections um and this is just the
sort of framing that will help us um
engage um communities residents and
other partners in understanding their
perspectives and opinions on the on the
draft priorities so the first one is is
about understanding what does thriving
communities mean um in in mids suffk um
what does it mean to the people who live
and work here um the second bit is
around um kind of understanding
perspectives and opinions on the
emerging priorities how do people feel
about them uh what might already be
happening in place that is useful to
bring into this work um the third part
is around resources so understanding the
current spending profile um and and you
know opinions and perspectives on on how
investment should be um made going
forward and then very finally and more
importantly in the work of new local is
to understand what is the great stuff
what are the assets and the initiatives
that are already happening in place that
enable you to really amplify the work
that you have planned um and creating
some of that as was said earlier some of
that um meaningful connection between
your communities your residents and your
partners to be able to do that in a
collaborative um and community-powered
way the method um on the left hand side
you'll see is twofold so we've got an
online survey um that we hope will go
live this week um tailored to
communities and residents and then also
something very specific for the business
Community again touching on all of the
same um sort of um uh aspects of this
engagement um but ensuring that um they
are able to respond um online um and
using citizen lab as the platform to do
that um and then secondly and probably
where our expertise um lies is to have
some facilitated sessions with those
communities who cannot access um an
online survey and who are often
neglected in conversations like this so
those seldom heard voices that will be
really important to understand their
perspectives and give them the
opportunity to contribute um to the
ongoing development of the corporate
plan um and I I want to dive into that
um a little bit deeper in a second but
just so you can see here here are some
of the engagement design highlights that
we have um so we've kind of blocked up
into three different groups and going
start on the right so we'll be
Consulting and engaging with Partners um
primarily with your towns and Parish
councils with your business community
and with the VCF SF organizations who
are already providing both connections
into the communities we want to hear
from but also providing that vital
support some of which you spoke about
earlier um to the communities that um
you want to engage with um we'll then be
kind of doing some engagement with staff
to understand the implications of those
insights that are emerging for the
corporate plan um and we'll be going out
to resident and communities um to
understand what are their perspectives
on the draft priorities um so again
we're going to try and do all of that
over the course of six weeks and and we
have a lot in the diary already um and
just to give you a sense here what is
really important about the way that we
have approached the engagement design is
to really be inclusive um and that means
reaching out into those communities um
where voice isn't isn't kind of a given
um and where we have to work extra hard
to really bring people into this process
and understand um how they currently
experience public services and life in
mid suffk as well as what they want to
see in the future um so we have worked
with corporate managers across the
council to identify what are those
groups now this isn't it's kind of
non-exhaustive list um there are
probably many more groups that we could
include um but we've tried to strike the
balance between uh where do we already
have information in the council that can
inform this process so that we avoid
that kind of consultation fatigue and
going out and asking the same questions
um multiple times to communities as well
as where do we have gaps in our
knowledge where could we um kind of
really afford to do more um and to
connect with some of those communities
um in a much deeper way um and so you
know in the table you'll see what the
groups are on the left hand side but
also on the right hand side you'll see
some of the Avenues to that connection
um and that we've been kind of assisted
by your vcsf organizations primarily um
to make those connections um and this is
kind of an evolving list as well so
we're we're continuously um kind of
adding new um connections and events um
to this uh
table just moving on then to the partner
engagement so as I said we'll be running
um Workshop sessions with towns and
parish councils as it was mentioned
earlier the kind of critical role they
play in delivering some vital core
services to communities um we'll be um
also engaging with the business
Community both in um the online survey
but also holding um some face-to-face
kind of meetings um I believe um the
project team will be out very soon with
invitations to some of those events uh
for counselors um to be involved in um
and and just to say a short note on um
your vcsf organizations we have seen
just absolutely tremendous support for
this um way of engaging with communities
um and I want to say that that's not
true everywhere um you know it has been
really heartwarming just to see how many
organizations really want to help us
connect with the communities who often
um get left behind and have really been
very gracious in offering us both their
time and sometimes physical space um to
host conversations as well as offering
their staff resources to help us um kind
of further those conversations even even
more um as well as like trying to
involve as many partners as possible we
understand the the validity and the
value in informing uh neighboring
district councils and other public
sector in institutions where
collaboration in the future might be
really vital so whilst we might not be
um engaging everybody and involving
everybody on commenting on the
priorities and giving their perspective
we're certainly going to take those
emerging insights and share them more
broadly and find those um aspects of
connection and and connectivity um and
Synergy where we
can um so very finally then um what next
um so we hope to um be able to kind of
launch the engagement process very soon
and when we have the engagement
activities sort of diarise there are a
number of different activities where we
would welcome um counselors to attend
and we think it's really important for
that um connection to happen um in
particular I will flag here the sessions
with the business community and the vcsf
community um will be really um uh sort
of important um to have some attendance
um overall the the kind of calendar for
Community sessions is shaping up nicely
we have roughly 24 events already
planned
about an equal split across bab and mids
suffk um and then we have some like very
specific asks so hopefully that gives
you a really kind of well-rounded view
of where the engagement is going um and
the activities we have planned so far
you are all Community facing I think you
have a really important role to play in
this so if you're spotting gaps or you
can see that there are other avenues to
connect with the communities that we're
targeting um please come and talk to us
we would welcome your um opinions and
your input here especially um um and
then very finally um we are developing
um a number of different kind of coms
collateral and materials to help you
talk about this engagement process
outwardly so whether that's postcards
that you can drop in um to your local
community center or a kind of local shop
or having those direct kind of
conversations with communities we want
to be able to equi you to kind of do
that in the best way possible so
alongside that media collateral we'll
also be running a session um where we
will talk you through the kinds of
conversations that we're having and how
to frame uh different parts of the
engagement uh in case you are interested
in doing that um and then obviously
there will always be opportunities for
you to Shadow and tag along and be part
of some of those events also I'm going
to pause there H thank you so much for
listening um and happy to take any
questions thank you very much that's a
very comprehensive plan and um it'd be
great to have a copy of those slides and
be able to look at those in detail
ground cons you couldn't see our screen
good okay anyone want to um ask any
questions uh cancel Stringer I've just
got one question your penultimate slide
can I just confirm that the two pictures
are at two different events and not the
same
event yes they are okay just check it
and actually the first picture is um the
C the rural coffee
Caravan making sure we weren't getting
young climate activists Pro testing at
rural coffee Caravan
events any other
questions counc
Weller thank thank you chair um and
thank you for the presentation I had a
couple of questions um particularly
around um engaging with the um seldom
heard voices and I wanted if you could
just expand a little on um
how how that piece of work is going to
happen and I'm thinking particularly
around the um that work that doesn't
involve online um engagement with the
process
thanks absolutely thanks so much for the
question um so primarily we will be
running what we're calling facilitated
sessions and the way that we have
organize that is to use the vcsf anchor
organizations and sometimes smaller vcsf
organizations
to um identify where these groups exist
like where do they show up where do they
feel most safe and most comfortable um
and how might we use existing events
already in the pipeline um to have a
conversation around the corporate plan
refresh and the emerging priorities for
mids suffk um so it's it's very varied
if I'm honest about how we will kind of
engage some of those are with through
the rural coffee Caravan sort of
sessions turning up having intimate
onetoone conversations with people um
understanding their needs understanding
the different ways in which to
communicate understanding the way that
we might need to tailor that overall
content framework that we showed you in
order to be able to um run a meaningful
engagement process with them other times
it's more formal um we will have a
workshop we'll invite uh kind of 25 odd
people to come uh they will be have been
identified as as kind of existing in one
of the categories that we've identified
um for targeting for the community
engagement so for example um suffk
libraries has been incredibly helpful to
us um that both in offering their time
their space and identifying the
communities and being able to promote um
this within their networks um and they
you know we might host a space for those
experiencing mental health illness and
again we would tailor our approach so
that it was really accessible to them
that's also not to say that we wouldn't
offer them to participate in the online
survey which is why we're developing the
posters and the postcards to be able to
leave behind um but primarily we want to
engage in a in a deeper conversation
around all of those topics um with those
seldom heard voices and currently um we
have good distribution across I think
there are 12 um good distribution across
all 12
groups thanks I did have a followup as
well if I may and and that's well I
guess there's two parts to this it's uh
what's what's the time scale for
completing this piece of work and um is
there to be any sort of interim
reporting before that piece of work's
finished
thanks uh so the deadline um is the 15th
of November and so that is when the
online survey will close and when we
hope we will be able to have held um
most of those facilitated workshops and
conversations um we we're allowing a
little bit of flex at the end there
because again we want to piggy back off
existing events and so if time permits
we will try and and do as many as we can
in order to get that really good
coverage um we will work with the bab
mids District Council project team to
develop a way of feeding in ongoing and
emerging insights so that you're not
waiting until the 15th of November to
hear back um but rather we can kind of
set a couple of different points where
we can either you know in whatever
format is most helpful either a short
paper or briefing um or a presentation
um so that you're fully aware of what's
emerging um and especially how that
might impact those draft priorities that
you
have does that
answer thank you and finally uh given
given the relatively short time scale
within which to achieve that are you
confident that you're up to it because
there's a lot to do there isn't there I
mean potentially there's a lot of
information to to glean from a lot of
different people
thanks great um um so it's not just me
which is um uh really good news for
being able to keep up with the many
different conversations that we're
having um I feel really confident that
we've had enough time to sort of line up
the conversation so we have
organizations who are sort of ready to
start you know actively promoting the
sessions in their networks with the
communities that we're trying to Target
which will just enable us to do so much
more as we get into the um real strides
of the engagement process um and then
you know we are numerous we're bringing
in um somebody who has very deep um kind
of community engagement expertise so she
will be deep in facilitating the
workshops um and kind of um having the
conversations and then we have a new
local team who will be kind of into
analyzing the insights as they emerge on
an ongoing basis making sure that we're
drafting as we're going and not waiting
until that sort of end date to be able
to do that um and then anything else
that we may require from the project
team um and a whole kind of Mighty bunch
of officers who sit in the background
here um who you know have worked really
hard to get us to this point and we'll
be working very hard to ensure that
we're learning as much as possible from
these really important conversations so
yes any further questions from uh
cabinet members C Theresa Council Davis
Hi um I'm just wondering about how
you're advertising to the wider public
of
mids in what different ways are you
doing any formal
advertising so we have um and and I
might um hand over to to Sarah in a
second but we have a supporting comm's
plan um so both an internal comms plan
and an external comms plan um like I
said that is waiting in the wings for us
to be able to promote I think what has
been really interesting and will help us
tremendously is the amount of
organizations who are who understand the
spaces that they're in and who are
willing to kind of push the message out
more broadly um so you know in the work
that we do with councils we often find
that a certain segment of the population
checks in on Council Twitter accounts
checks the council website and we really
want to make sure that we're going
beyond that so having other people who
can advocate for the engagement process
and be able to promote and support it in
their own networks is a key sort of
strategy that we're trying to use um and
and so we hope that will enable us to
probably get into the spaces and the
corners of Ms suffk um that perhaps we
wouldn't get through if we were only
using Council channels I don't know
Sarah if you wanted
to thank you yes just to give some
reassurance we appreciate that you know
what we're asking is for lots of
Engagement and therefore we need to be
able to get that message out there um so
absolutely social media will play a
large part in helping get that message
out we've also so um preparing
Communications that we can release
through our Media Partners um following
today's cabinet if approved that will
again help that but actually yourselves
and other counselors will also be really
critical to getting the message out
there um and hopefully we can ask you to
um to Lia with your colleagues to Lia
with your with your residents and
encourage that that message of
Engagement obviously we've got lots of
links um across the organization as as a
staff coach
as well so we're absolutely asking our
corporate managers where they're having
touch points with other organizations to
to keep um to keep on that message over
the six week period that there's a
variety of different ways to engage with
us on this um corporate plan refresh and
to encourage that so we've got lots of
different um avenues that we're
exploring um and and you know to keep
that message out
there thank
you any further
questions um so we do need a a proposer
and and second for this um for this
report I'm happy to propose it from the
chair do we have a second councelor
eburn thank
you
um so I will now open the item Up For
Debate we've we've had questions on it
does anyone want to contribute to the
debate councelor Stringer first then
councelor e thank you chair uh just want
to say a few words about this it's odd
before I came here today somebody asked
me in the cafe across the road what
business are you doing today at the
council well we're we're looking at a
corporate plan refresh and when they
stop yawning I Then I then explain to
them actually what it was doing uh and
what it was attempting to do because it
does sound on paper quite dry but it
does completely set the direction the
speed the velocity who we take with us
uh and and and and where all the
resources will be channeled towards uh
and and actually will will really
be the tool that's used to S of really
launch the direction and and what future
results we get so it's actually
incredibly important and it is really
important that we get the communications
right and get all of those that didn't
know they wanted to engage to engage
including the person that thought it was
dry and Dusty um that will be the
challenge but I think it's quite
exciting what we've heard in in terms of
what you're going to be bringing to the
table and it's also I think one one of
the the mantras we want to use with this
council is we want to work with
communities not do to them and that that
is really refreshing to see you want to
you really want to work with uh which
which is really really good uh so yeah I
think it'll be uh a challenge in in more
than one way but I think it's it's it's
this is a really good start to
refreshing that that corporate plan
which will be our you know blueprint
certainly for the next few years thank
you thank you coun
eurn um thank you very much chair I
think um overall we've got there's a
very um ambitious and and Broad scope of
what we want to be achieving um at this
Council um and you know as of
highlighted you know putting um social
environmental responsibilities at the
heart of that to ensure we've got
resilient and and in thriving
communities and and to reh highlight
what my colleague um Council Stringer
said in terms of you know we want to
ensure that um communities feel that we
are working with them and we're not it's
not done to so we are not producing
polies policies that are then done and
onto placed onto communities and I think
we we are all part of communities we're
all part of of multiple communities you
know starting with where where we live
and I think everybody here wants to see
the absolute best that um we can get get
um for those communities um enriching
the the the lives um and ensuring that
um we we take them with us as within
this um overall plan um and and I too
hate the words corporate plan but there
we are that's um that's what we're work
working with but I think it's it's
ultimately it's really really important
to hear as many voices as we can and to
ensure that they are um their views are
heard and that we can we're really
listen listening to that and I would say
that this is a a first start um I think
if we'd had it
um a year to plan this nine months or
whatever you know we would actually be
be doing you know more and I would hope
that in the future we can actually
engage you know um I've hesitate to use
the word constantly but but be always
engaging with our with our communities
in terms of of of what we're doing and
how that how um any anything that the
council is working with is affecting the
lives of those um communities and again
ensuring um that we do we do listen but
as I said we have an ambitious plan and
it's it would be really fantastic to to
hear what um people have to say and I
look forward to to seeing what we get
thank
you councelor winch um just to reate
what councilor eburn just said I think
it's a very comprehensive Community
engagement plan uh it will be really
interesting to see what feedback we get
from that and I think it's a bit of a
model for what we would like to do going
forward on on other initiatives uh we
don't want to be a top down we're
telling you what to do type environment
we want to take feedback from the
community to try and get the best
Solutions so um I'm really looking
forward to the
feedback any further contributions to
debate uh if not I'll say a few words
myself then so um we realized there is a
a tight timetable on this consultation
and a timetable uh that's pretty tight
to get the final document out but we do
want to align the corporate plan with
the budget planning so that the two kind
of come together in early
um and very grateful to the the work
that officers have done will do and uh
continue to do in the future um to make
this happen um people can sometimes be
sort of fairly cynical about
consultations you know you've already
made up your minds now you just want us
to sign it off but I think this is a
genuine attempt to hear from our
communities uh and end up with something
which people are um have some ownership
in we kind of know where we want to go
with things but we do want to take
people with us um and I think at the end
of the day we'll have a plan which will
give our staff a clear direction for uh
what the council is doing over the next
few years so um again very grateful to
the officers involved to Joe Hop's
corporate manager for strategic policy
and our team to Sarah wilop there and uh
others who have been involved in this uh
so far and will be in the next few
months um and I think I can now ask the
governor's officer to conduct the vote
on the recommendation to endorse
engagement on the emerging vision and
strategic priorities as set out in
appendix
a
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress thank you members that is six
votes for that's carried thank you very
much so we now move on to item 11 this
is M paper MCA stroke 23 stroke 20 the
midu district council ring fence funding
for electric bus stroke rural transport
provision and I'll now invite the
cabinet member for thriving towns of
rural communities Teresa Davis to
introduce the
report thank you okay um in February
2022 we saw the budget amended to
include funding for scheduled rural
community Transport using zeroc carbon
electric buses officers researched this
and provided a summary of which is in
the appendex this summary paused the
project in February 2023 for six months
officers have continued to research and
Lia with a range of Partners and key
stakeholders to understand steps needed
for success success seems to depend on
awareness of demand rev reliability of
the service flexibility to overcome
restraints and awareness of choice for
potential
users three options have been provided
to Cabinet however I would very much
like option three to be our chosen
future working
model option three sets out to deliver
public transport across mid suffk in as
little time as possible by foregoing the
immediate need to use electric buses
which have an approximate delivery time
delay of two
years it also stipulates set routs with
definitive stops as well as a virtual
and fully accessible booking system it
aims to progress the transport Provider
from a sustainable fuel such as biofuel
on a onto a sustainable vehicle which
allows for us to harness new technology
and funding such as is zebra which only
recently became available in September
for suffa County
Council the grant scheme also enables us
to caveat certain needs such as working
in Partnership for commuter
Services the grant seam also enables us
to best fit on needs and using a
multimodal sustainable transport
approach that's all I have to say and I
hope people will opt for option
three thank you we need a a proposal and
second for this uh um this report so
councilor Davis you're going to propose
do we have a second then councelor
Weller thank you so any questions um
from cabinet members and we have uh
Katherine Davis F Dil here to uh who can
answer some of the questions if if um
they go beyond what Teresa's uh able to
answer C
Eben um thank you chair
it's it's kind of more just getting
confirmation really in terms of the um
this uh paper that we've got before us
today is one where we it it really
highlights one of the the key things
that we want to do as an Administration
and I just want confirmation that we
will have enough resource um at the
council in order to um take this forward
thank you
chair not sure where that answer is
going to come from it might be to the
person on my right so well happy to give
it a go and particularly in the absence
of the section1 officer she might give a
different answer um linking this report
to the previous report I think the
honest answer is it depends uh and I say
that because if politically your
Ambitions that come through the
corporate plan vastly outstrip this item
then no you won't have sufficient
resource to do both but as things stand
yes I think you
have Council
Stringer yeah I I think I know the
answer to this one but I'll ask it
anyway uh during the planning process of
the last few years uh there's often been
uh payments going to the County Council
uh for uh improvements of bus services
in in response to approval of of new
homes
certainly in some rural areas uh and in
fact the approvals have been based on
there being a bus service there which
has since in many cases dwindled are we
able to access any of that section 106
money back to the district council if we
are then going to be helping to provide
those bus
services thanks for the question
um is anyone going to volunteer to
answer that
one yeah I can have a go answering that
Katherine Davis thank you uh so we do
just need to check the specific wording
agreement of each individual case where
that has
happened any further
questions okay question for me from me
for the officers then
um option three um is a kind of
pragmatic approach I guess uh with the
with the the fact that we can't get
electric buses anytime soon but it
doesn't can I just check it doesn't rule
out the the potential for electric buses
should they become
available um yes it absolutely doesn't
rule out the potential for electric
buses in the future um and one thing to
note is the proposal to hold back some
of the funding uh to put towards um a
partnership bid with suff County Council
um for some zero Electric zero emission
buses um from a national government
grant scheme that is emerging
currently good thank you very much
councilor winch yeah the the document
mentions the E suffer catch service
which was started with electric buses
then stopped and as I understand it's
been reinstated with a new app but with
diesel buses have we had any further
feedback as to what what exactly went on
there we do now have um a feedback
report from that um that that has landed
in my inbox um subsequent to submitting
this report so we'll be analyzing that
but we we also have access to talk to
the officers who who ran that project um
and get sort of friendly and critical
friend advice from
them um my understanding was that the
the the range the battery range on the
vehicles that were used uh did not
deliver as expected so that was one sort
of real logistical problem with
delivering with electric vehicles for
that particular
pilot any further
questions if not I'll open this item Up
For Debate does anyone want to make a
comment councelor winch yeah I think
this illustrates our commitment to doing
to making improvements in rural
transport um I really strong favor
option three for three reasons number
one it's quick we can get some quick
results so hopefully early next year we
can see things happening uh there's less
Financial Risk uh and it's flexible so
depending on what operator we're
speaking to we can adapt exactly what we
do if there's electric buses available
via Gateway 14 we can do something so
it's it's much more flexible so I'm
strongly in favor of option
three thank you very much cast Eber
um thank you chair yes I I would also be
um supporting option three um I think
this um will help address an issue which
um communities are crying out for and um
just to go back to the question that I
asked I think the key thing was we had
we had money set aside for this back in
February
2022 um so um we you know yes we are
developing a a a corporate plan but we
do need to actually be getting on with
the um what was what been intended to do
um 18 months ago as it well so I think
it's very very important that we really
press ahead with this and I think just
with regards to the to um the resource
I'm I'm aware that we have um a very
small team at mids suffk as it were um
working on this so I would you know um
wherever we can support that then that
would be um really good um and I think
um we do you know there are it's not a
one siiz fit all there are several
different options that um we could do in
order to kind of meet the needs of our
communities and um we need to be you
know looking looking at those so as I
say very happy to support this thank you
chair thank you very much anyone
else okay well I'll just make a few
comments myself obviously um public
transport has largely been the kind of
uh the area where the County Council has
been involved um uh and there has been a
obviously a big hit on public transport
particularly buses from coid you know
people were essentially told you know if
you get on a a bus you know you're going
to catch something which could kill you
and and understandably people um avoided
getting on buses for a while and it's
taken a while for people to to go back
to bus services uh and despite the fact
that there's been various government
support plans uh under in the bus
services there has been kind of
reduction in what's available um over
the last few years even before
coid um I think it's really important in
this area that we're kind of keyed up
for partnership working um you know
money becomes available funding becomes
available in different pots and from
different directions and we need to be
fairly flexible and try and uh work with
Partners like the county to access those
and provide the service that our
communities looking for it's a fast
changing
situation um and you know this this this
most recent bit of funding was was only
announced a couple of weeks ago um but I
think it's really important that we try
and move forward with this option three
is the the pragmatic option that gets us
something on the ground while we look
into the the new technology and and see
how that is is um improving and coming
forward from the market so I'm very
happy to Support options
three um if there's no further comments
I think we can uh I'll just read the
recommendations and then we can go to
the vote so the recommendations 2.1 that
cabinet agrees for officers to proceed
with the option three proposal outlined
in section four of this report whilst
recognizing the associated risks and the
limitations with regards to evidence
currently available that this investment
will be feasible and offer good value
for money 2.2 that cabinet informs offic
of any further stipulations they wish to
be added to the proposed next steps I
don't think we have any at this
stage and 2.3 that cabinet delegate the
further development and delivery of
option three to the director of economic
growth and climate change in
consultation with the cabinet member for
thriving towns and Rural communities and
I think on that basis we can uh go to
the
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress you will have to scroll down a
little bit to get through the blue line
that's six votes for that's carried
chair thank you very much uh thank you
to the officers for uh for the
report so we move on to item 12 uh this
is paper MCA stroke 23 stroke
21 um the uh babber and mids District
council's Electric Vehicle
infrastructure implementation
implementation plan um and I will now
invite the cabinet member for thriving
towns of rural communities to introduce
the
report thank
you okay it was agreed in 2020 that we
have an aspiration of being Net Zero by
2030 our recent mids suffk statistical
analysis showed our transport as being
approximately a third of our
emissions our electric vehicle
infrastructure implementation plan or
evip and the gis mappin has been
produced to plot existing and ongoing
public EV charging points and to give
details on how mids suffer play their
part in the roll out of the Regal and
National
infrastructure of
EV suff EV ready report modeled
predictions were used on a best and
worst case scenario for public available
charge points up to
2040 the evip addresses where mids
suffer might install on their own land
and help communities and
business with these
installations the areas suggested in the
plan are not set in stone and they will
be subject to feasibility for example
the cost of upgrading a power supply at
that specific
place the evip is comprehensive and will
Aid in serving funding and planning for
the
future I'm asking cabinet today to
approve having an EV as our starting
framework for electric vehicle charging
as I feel it important that we are
actively monitoring implementing and
encouraging this
infrastructure and I propose for us to
take it on thank you do we have a second
out councelor Ean thank you very
much uh any questions from
Members CC
yeah thank you chair
um having had an electric vehicle myself
for about five years now um interesting
transition uh many good things but also
many challenges and one of the
challenges is uh the regular
availability of the infrastructure
Network and that has been incredibly
variable um is it possible to implement
into the policy a way of monitoring
how often the infrastructure is is
unavailable because that certainly is
one of the biggest bug Bears to an owner
and obviously one of the huge barriers
to people wishing or considering
migrating over to uh electric vehicles
and if we want to maximize the latter we
we need to build confidence that it's
not just about installing a bright and
shiny new charger it's about making sure
it works every time it's need needed in
year 1 2 3 and and continuing so I I
would ask what measures are we putting
in place to monitor how often the
infrastructure is
available um thank you for your question
so uh We've now brought uh or diverted
one of our offices in the climate change
team to uh keep a regular log of
monitoring um and a much more regular
set of updates from the uh back office
operators of the individual charge
points one of the issues we have at the
moment is some of the historic charge
points um there wasn't really a
strategic plan in terms of the back
office management of those so so they're
all managed by different people so uh
one of the things we're hoping is as
they come out of contract we can uh in
probably a year's time we can let a
single contract for all of all of the uh
electric vehicle charge points so it
will make the monitoring a bit EAS yeah
um the other challenge we have which is
just a very practical challenge is um
they run on availability of of sort of
um Wi-Fi connection and as we all know
that can come and go so uh I think
something we can put in the plan that we
can look at is how they can be more um
how we can get them more attached to
perhaps some um more secure forms of
broadband um because that that's part of
the issue why they they work and then
don't work but in terms of the actual
monitoring we have now got a dedicated
officer with with responsibility for
keeping on top of the monitoring um and
hopefully identifying any trends that we
might need to
rectify it it's slightly concerning that
we're going to be relying on the service
providers back office data because that
that's with certainly my experience
Where it All Falls Down um when they
will say well I'll switch it on remotely
for you and then they don't switch it on
so their data shows that they they've
fulfilled it but when in fact they
haven't uh and it's quite noticeable
there there are a number that that
regularly do not work um and and
incidentally one of them is slapped next
door to one of our car parking machines
which actually works almost every single
time so if I can use a debit card in
your car park machine and it works every
time why can't it work every time in the
machine that's right next door to it so
in terms of I I think we we probably
ought to even in the short term perhaps
do try and do a bit of monitoring or
have a way we can gather data to make
sure that our service provider is living
up to their commitment thank
you any further questions
Teresa um in in response to that I'm
thinking that we put this within the
tender when the tender goes out to
ensure that that streamline of
communication is dealt with
any further
questions if not I can open up this item
for
debate um does anyone want to debate
this item councelor winch yeah it's
really good to hear that we're going to
put in a monitoring process because I I
can't emphasize strongly enough that the
the reliability is absolutely critical
I'd rather have less points that were
100% reliable because it just bring the
whole thing into distribut it's
absolutely critical the other thing I
wanted to mention that isn't in the
document is is pricing and generally if
you've got a home car charger you're not
so worried about the price you're
worried about reliability and speed some
of these charge points or most of them
are being put in because people will not
have the ability to have their own home
charges so therefore in these cases the
pricing matters a lot more because it's
going to be very expensive to run the
vehicle so so I think the overall
pricing strategy should be more explicit
in in the document going
forward
Teresa well with regards to the pricing
the pricing is reasonably set at 48 P at
the moment across the board um but I
don't think because there's always
movement in pricing that we can
potentially um set a price in the
document in addition to that there's
also um the um obvious obstacle that
users currently have we've implemented
these charges for people that are
off-road um they cannot they don't have
any um off-road parking so they're going
to the car parks of an evening charging
their cars overnight they're still
having to pay um 20% VAT on this whereas
if someone charged their car at home
they'd only be paying 5% and that's a
National thing that we need to have
addressed as well so the the pricing
issue I'm not sure that we have enough
information yet to place that in this
existing document but I will defer to my
specialist probably better that an
obious of comments but my understanding
is currently our pricing is below the
rest of the market so there's a decision
to be made as to whether we keep it low
or whether we try and put it more in
line with market pricing and all I'm
saying is because these charges are
there for people who haven't got the
home option we need to be much more
cautious about just moving to market
pricing than if we if we had a charger
on the A14 fair enough let's just make
it market pricing
yeah would you like me to come in um so
it is quite difficult um for the reasons
as councilor Davis pointed out to put
anything specific in this plan because
this plan will have some longevity and
pricing will change not least the power
cost uh changes we have done quite a lot
of analysis we are um considerably
cheaper than your average commercial
charge Point um one thing that we could
do is make some reference in the plan to
um Regular review o of of that pricing
um maybe annual review of the pricing to
make sure it's fair and you know
accessible to all so we could we could
add that
too C
um thank you very much chair I think I
think it's very important that we've got
a plan like this in place and I think
that it's you know with a with a
changing circumstances of EV charging
and so on it's it's good to have it and
I'm particularly pleased as well to see
the um where the where we're looking at
community-led infrastructure because we
get inquiries constantly I know many V
Village hes have already got things in
place um and just to get some support on
that um going forward is is really good
thank
you
any other
comments so just to add my two pen um as
I've I've been using an electric car for
18 months now uh certainly wouldn't go
back um there is an issue occasionally
about
accessing um a working charge Point um
but actually slow Market is really
really well served now we must be one of
the towns in the country in terms of the
amount of charge points we've got uh and
mostly they work I've had one occasion
when I've tried to plug in and had to
had to phone um you know the office and
get them to reset it which happened and
it worked um but um that the funding
that came forward for those charge
points
was you know so that people who don't
have access to uh a driveway could
charge their electric vehicle um it's
great that they're available during the
day for um visitors um my car is is
parked up at Stone Market charging at
this moment um but also they are there
for people so they can go in the car
park overnight and and and plug in and
charge up um so we need to sort of
promote that amongst people in Stow
Market but I think we're doing really
well I'm very pleased with this plan and
I'm certainly happy to vote for it and
if there's no further comments I think
we can uh I'll just read the
recommendations and we can move to the
vote so the recommendations
3.1 recommendation that option one is
taken forward in the joint council's
draft EV infrastructure implementation
plan is approved 3.2 that the completion
of the final documentation is delegated
to the director for economic growth and
climate change in consultation with the
portfolio holders for environment
culture and well-being in Baba and the
thriving towns of rural communities in
Med
suffk so uh I can now ask the governor
officer to conduct the vote thank you
chair the vote is in progress uh you
need to scroll down to reach the blue
line thank you members uh that is six
votes for that's
carried thank you very
much um we still got two items on the
agenda does anyone need a break or we
happy to carry on and get it done yeah
okay so uh item 13 paper MCA stroke 23
st22 um employer supported volunteering
policy um I will now we got we've got um
Tom Barker uh interim director dtor for
communities and wellbeing and Vicky
Mosley corporate manager for communities
here to support this paper uh I'll now
invite the cabinet member for thriving
towns and Rural communities to introduce
the report oh no it's you sorry it's Tim
is it
sorry the cabinet member for um I'm
going to get this wrong environment
well-being and culture thank you
Tim thank you chair um as keenly
demonstrated during the pandemic
volunteers are an integral and vital
part of an active and engaged community
and we see the difference volunteers
make across mids suffk every day I'd
like to take this opportunity to thank
the many volunteers who give generously
of their time skills and experience to
support our communities in a diverse
range of
ways between March 2020 and may 2021
however nationally around one in three
voluntary Community faith and social
Enterprise organizations reported a
decline in the number of volunteers and
that decline aligns with the current
experience of vcfs groups across our
district implementation of an employer
supported volunteer scheme has potential
to deliver positive impacts for mids
suffit District Council the local
community as well as well-being effect
benefits uh for those undertaking
volunteering creating a win-win
situation for all
involved recipient organizations gain
skills advice and expertise while
employees achieve a sense of giving back
and making a difference in return the
council enhances its Community presence
and reputation with employees residents
and wider
Society through an ESV scheme the
council can support its work towards
creating social value and contribute to
its priority
outcomes the council currently have no
formal policy on volunteering and do not
actively offer any provision for
employee support supported volunteering
unlike many of our partner and
neighboring authorities including suff
County Council IP switch Bar Council and
East suffet District Council all of
which support their staff to volunteer
or engage with voluntary bodies through
employers supported
volunteering so this will be the first
employer supported volunteering policy
for midet Council and I'm both excited
and pleased to present this report today
whilst thanking the officers involved in
drafting it I therefore invite cabinet
to note and support the implementation
of the policy thank
you thank you um do we have a um
seconder for
this councelor Davis thank you any
questions for
members open up this item for debate
then um does anyone want to contribute
to the debate councelor Stringer yeah
clear an interest I I volunteer myself
for a few things too many to go through
now uh with with actually one of them
some officers from this Council um I
have to say this is a really good paper
I I wish we had had a paper like this a
decade ago I think um volunteering
opportunities is is really good for
those that get involved but actually I
think there's something hugely in it for
the council uh it's a way of making sure
that we are firmly rooted into those
communities that we serve uh and those
those little tendrils going out into all
the various
volunteer stuff that we get involved is
is is absolutely vital to make sure that
we as it were keep our feet on the
ground it's it's an incredible leveler
and actually should be a great inform of
policy uh because I think councils are
often seen as being incredibly remote
that you do just what they want to do
and they're not held to account and all
that kind having us root root and Branch
into our communities in all sorts of
areas I think that's incredibly vital um
and and that's say I just wish we' had a
firm policy like this over a decade ago
but but let's crack on with this one I
think I nothing but support from this
it's just one cab I'd I'd just like to
to mention and this comment is not uh
meant to be political but I have to say
today we've gone through a number of
things about the Strategic direction of
this Council
and 10 of the counselors that are not in
the administration not one of them are
in the room today I think that's
actually quite disappointing that we're
not being held to account for what we're
discussing today so could I ask the
chair to write to the groups opposite
just to remind them of what we're doing
here at cabinet it'd be really good if
they could attend you know there could
be various reasons why we've got no one
but I think it's vitally important we
are held to account thank
you yeah thank you for that comment um
I'm sure the uh the uh the uh the party
conferen season may have something to do
with
non-attendance um councelor
Ean um thank you very much chair I just
to say you know as has been said by that
um volunteers um and people giving up
their times launes is incredibly
important and Incredibly valuable um and
I think without volunteers you know many
organizations and Community groups just
wouldn't be able to do the Fantastic
work that they do and um you know we're
all aware that um many of the employees
at mids suffk already volunteer and give
up their time their spare time to um to
contribute to different organizations so
I think it's really good to be able to
put this into a into a formal policy and
I would very much be supporting it thank
you thank you any other
comments um question from me then for
the the staff um obviously this this
policy encourages staff to take part in
volunteering how many or what percentage
of our staff do we do we think are going
to take up this
opportunity thank thank you thank you um
thanks for the question I will probably
pass you on to B so I just want to
congratulate b as well because it was um
be who produced and developed this paper
and has been working alongside um
Community Action suff as well and also
supports or represents the Council on a
kind of a countywide group to support
the countywide um volunteering strategy
as well so I want to just give some
credit to or a lot of credit to be for
the development of this policy rather
than myself um we have done a a sort of
a quick survey through working together
of staff that currently um volunteer um
we also in the report sort of list the
typical response from um other
organizations of the County Council and
and wi so if I could pass on to be to
provide you with some of the detail
around a the staff survey um but also
then typical numbers that we would like
to see but also we are looking to um
promote the policies um but also we are
actively working on a particular um
promotional piece at the moment around
how we support and value and thank our
volunteers within the council as well
and be can provide you with a bit of an
update on where we've got to with that
particular piece of work as
well that's great thank you Bethany
sorry for not introducing you earlier
thanks for coming and great to hear what
what you're
doing sorry thank you very much thank
you for the question um as Vicky said we
did do a survey of Staff within the
council to that I think we had about 68
responses um and within that I think I
believe it was around 60% of those 68
responses did volunteer in terms of
uptake of the policy if you're looking
at National levels um there going to be
around hopefully around 20% uptake but
if we look at the um because I have also
been in touch with our partners so suff
County Council their uptake level is
just 2% so we'd obviously hope it would
be a lot more than that
um
was it um the um ding our volunteers the
particular Pro promotional piece about
thank youing our volunteers yes so we
have um launched a campaign around
valuable volunteers which is recognizing
the staff that already volunteer in
their time outside of work um within
that we are looking to thank the thank
the staff members who do volunteer but
also trying to get to the heart of
what's really important about volunte
volunteering which is um people do it
because they care about the cause that
they're volunteering for um so we are
are um as part of that giving a donation
from the council so £50 to each
organization as well um so far we have
had some nominations coming in we will
be promoting that in the next few weeks
as well with nominations closing I
believe on the 20th of October and more
information around that will follow as
well yeah and just just to say that
that's you know it's a small amount of
money that goes back into that voluntary
organization but again we see that
relatively small amounts of money can
generate significant amounts of um
support for our communities and we've
seen that with various different Grant
schemes that we've um we've completed in
the last year around warm spaces and
things like that so um it's just a it's
just a thank you um and I can say that
we also keep an eye on kind of what that
funding has been allocated to and the
benefits and the impact that has even if
it might just be sort of small but
collectively it might be you know
hopefully it'll be quite
significant
Tom Barker uh yes first of all just
again thanks to Bethany first time in
cabinet um so well done um your nerves
are coming through a little bit but no
no no brilliant brilliant I think we
should look to get up to 50% of our
staff who are volunteering in our
communities it would be far beyond what
the national average is but taking on
board councelor stringers points which I
wholeheartedly endorse the the extent to
which it Roots us within our community
given that our headquarters is is here
and there's a a strong desire to be more
locally connected I think we should be
looking to get up to 50% personally I'm
a great believer that the professional
skills that our staff could provide to
the voluntary sector could make a
massive difference to the voluntary
sector there's some balancing to do
there because some people might prefer
to do something that isn't their day job
when they're out volunteering within the
community and we need to find the
balance where it's both providing for
the kind of the well-being of our staff
and their kind of motivation and
productivity the connections into our
community and then the benefits to the
VCS organizations themselves and we need
to make sure that we're kind of
optimizing that balance but I'd like to
get us up to 50% at
least that's great to hear about that
ambition U yeah let's let's hope it
happens
so if there's no further debate on this
I think we can uh move to the
recommendation 3.1 to note and support
the imple implementation of the
council's first employer supported
volunteering policy and I'll ask the
governance officer to conduct the vote
or do we need to vote do we need to vote
we do
okay thank you chair the vote is in
progress
thanks
thank you members uh that's six votes
for that's carried
thanks thank you very much thank you to
Tom and Vicki and Bethany for that item
so we move on to item 14 this is paper
MCA stroke
23 stroke 23 revise safeguarding policy
for children young people and adults at
risk and uh Tom and Vicki are here to
support and I think Rachel Young are
here to support this item as well thank
you very much and I invite the cabinet
member for environment culture and
well-being to introduce the
report thank you
chair the purpose of this report is to
ask cabinet to approve the revised
safeguarding policy to ensure that an
overarching approach to safeguarding is
bedded across the council identifying
roles and responsibilities of employees
counselors and
volunteers this revised policy outlines
the procedures to be adopted by the
council in ensuring the safety of
children young people and adults at
risk the revised policy picks up all
current legislative requirements and
expectations of local authorities and
provides an easyto use set of guidance
on how to report a safeguarding
concern to support this policy officers
have developed a thorough and detailed
action plan which will see an increased
focus on regular annual review of the
policy via the council's section 11
audit process greater sharing of related
guidance and procedures employee and
counselor training and the development
of a council-wide safeguarding Champions
group made up of officers and from
Frontline teams to share information and
best
practice the policy has been shared and
consulted on with an extensive list of
Partners including the suffk
safeguarding partnership our health
alliances local Authority partners and
the safeguarding training team at
Community Action
suffk along with those agencies I
complement officers on this revised
policy together with its comprehensive
and intuitive
guidance so in commenting it to Cabinet
I propose approval of the revised
safeguarding policy for children young
people and adults at
risk um one of the recommendations is to
agree that the deputy chief executive in
consultation with the portfolio Holder
have delegated authority to make minor
amendments to the policy and that's one
of the recommendations that we're asked
to vote on here and I'm going to suggest
at this point that if cabinets minded to
adopt the policy um that one of the
things we might we might uh include as
part of that uh agreement for the deputy
chief exac and myself as po portfolio
holded to make minor amendments to the
policy that we might do one immediately
following this meeting uh and that's to
uh make a couple of adjustments which
only noticed when reviewing the paper
late last night uh in relation to
citation of the children and social work
act 2017 which I'm sure um Keen members
will have noted is a piece of
legislation that does exist in real life
but doesn't exist in the way it's been
cited in the paper so it's so care has
been added and Care is great but it's
not part of that legislation and the
other amendment that I think needs to be
made is just an amendment to um adjust
the styling of the cabinet member
responsible because uh I think currently
it it cites a cabinet members portfolio
that doesn't exist but I'm sure that's a
very minor Amendment which just makes
the uh the document foolproof going
forward but of course that will only be
amended if cabinet um approve the policy
and that's what I'm invoking cabinet
might do thank
you thank you councelor do we have a
second uh councelor Davis thank
you any questions from
Members councelor winch can we just
clarify how this is going to be
publicized within the wider group this
just new
policy I might ask uh the deputy chief
exec to come in to talk about the
communication
methods using various methods to put
this out to staff including our working
together newsletter and team
meetings thank you any further questions
if not I will open this item Up For
Debate does anyone want to contribute to
the
debate councelor winch well it's I think
is absolutely essential we have a policy
like this in place uh I think it's
comprehensive and it's very clear and
easy to read so I I'd highly recommend
that we vote for
it thank you anyone
else
uh I think in that case uh we can move
to the vote the recommendations I will
just read them for clarity and thank you
Tim for your attention to the detail
there um 3.1 to agree option one and
approve the revised safeguarding policy
for children young people and adults at
risk 3.2 to agree for the deputy chief
executive in consultation with the
portfolio holder to have delegated
authority to make minor amendments to
the safeguarding policy in line with
outcomes derived from the annual section
11 audit or future or future internal
audit reviews and it sounds like some of
those amendments will be made
immediately uh so those are the
recommendations and I think we can move
to the
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you members that is six votes for
and that's carried
thanks thank you very much thank you to
members for their work this morning and
for the officers who supported the
papers that come forward uh our next
meeting is scheduled for Tuesday the 7th
of November at 9:30 a.m. I assume we're
back in here are we
I'm afraid not chair we will be
elsewhere okay venue to be confirmed
thank you very much and I declare the
meeting
closed